Where do the concepts of left and right
to classify political positions come from?
28/05/1789 the National Constituent Assembly took place in France,
they wanted to draft a new constitution and
debate the power that the 16th King Louis should have.
But as when groups were made in the class
halls on the right sat the most privileged classes,
members of the monarchy,
high nobility and the,
and on the left were those who represented the middle and popular classes,
the promoters of abolishing the absolutist regime and promoting democracy,
the revolutionaries.
Well, parentheses,
yes, I am sorry,
sisters,
it has not yet come to our time because
these canijos promoted only the male vote.
Although olamp the gush made the voice of the marginalized heard in this
discussion through his work Declaration of the
Rights of Women and Citizens in 1 791.
But well,
that's another story In short,
on the right those who wanted to maintain the Régime and
on the left those who wanted a radical change of order.
Hey save the religious analogy The good guys will be sitting to the
right of the father Remember From there it is explained a bit that
the left was born with a bad reputationically the homeland is served
The terms today do not mean the same but this binomial helps us
explain the spectrum of political trends by updating the topics of discussion.
If you're interested in learning a little more about this,
let me know in the comments.